dollar what's up dude
hey are you doing rich
yeah rich yeah the the thing about it is
that youtube is that i don't know why
they haven't yet banned those you know
blackpill channels such as you know like
guys like wet waffles or there's another
guy
let's not name any names here yeah okay
yeah so these guys
are brainwashing these young kids
without giving them any solutions right
yeah and these young a lot of these high
school boys
and a lot of these college guys they
watch these videos and they actually
believe what they're preaching and have
you noticed that all these guys these
black people right
none of them show off their face correct
yet they and people actually believe
them without
seeing them like
making sense and that's the funny thing
because a lot of these like
guys will
see stuff like my content and they'll
call me a pickup artist or a pua
and and say that i'm a snake oil
salesman
right well where exactly is the snake
oil that i'm selling
where
where have i shown you that but instead
what they're selling is doom and gloom
they're the real snake oil salesman they
they're they're cowards they won't show
their face
right right
some of them might argue that they're
not good looking enough and that's why
they don't show it or maybe they don't
want to lose their job
but that just tells me look if you're
not man enough to show your face then
don't bother talking about something
because you're not an expert on it if
you're a coward it's as simple as that
right now
what can you do about it well if you
trip across it
in the comments just tell them you know
why do you guys watch this stuff like
this is all doom and gloom why don't you
go look at something that's uplifting
why don't you go find a solution to this
problem why is it always just complain
complain complain
as far as you know what the platform
does with it
look
i'm not for
um censorship i'm really not a big fan
of like the way uh big tech you know
treats like
even with my content right like i talk
about stuff that helps guys become
better versions of themselves yeah
but the problem is is that because i
have some reach and there's some views
sometimes you're going to get these
people going to say oh he's an insult or
he's a misogynist or he's a you know
insert whatever narrative that they want
to label you with right
and that's going to
like once you start to unravel the uh
wrapping of
you know the whole well let's start
censoring people
you know if if guys would just take
their attention elsewhere
and not and realize watching loser
content is going to make them a loser
like you hang out with five fat broke
people you're gonna be the six you hang
out with five fat broke people that
aren't getting the girls you're gonna be
the six
why hang out with these people why not
find somebody that can help you
understand what women are actually
attracted to maybe find things that you
can do to improve your level of
attraction to get some better results
and then you can get it's much easier
it's much easier to sell the victim
mindset to these young boys without
telling them to put the work into it so
well there's a reason why whenever you
drive on the highway and there's a car
accident even if it's on the other side
both lanes slow down to a crawl because
everybody likes to look at a colossal
train wreck like they want to see misery
they want to see the blood and guts like
that's how humans are right like
they're they're they're more prone and
they're more attracted to negativity
that's why drama sells right like um
some of the
some of the channels that this kid jake
davis was subscribed to were not in that
category but in fact in categories that
i've talked about as well which i
discourage guys from watching which is
stuff that uh basically tries to hold
women accountable and makes them look
bad right oh look all women are like
these ones over here because this is how
they're behaving on our show
right like he was consuming content like
that as well and i've said for a long
time stop watching that crap there's no
solutions offered it's just drama
right so if guys take their attention
away from that and they go and apply it
on themselves or content maybe like mine
that says hey look you know
uh this is this is what you need to know
about single moms for example and here's
you know the main points and this is how
you you know want to navigate around
that then you know you've got some value
with it you know then you can do
something with the next time it shows up
in your life
exactly and the thing is
when you or olo or other dudes who try
to help these
young generation and they're always
blaming you and calling you like
different names and saying that you're
trying to take advantage of them on the
other hand they're
how that's what i love like how do i
take advantage of guys exactly
there's no explanation whatsoever oh he
sells soap well aren't you taking
showers like don't you use soap if you
don't want to use this soap then use
whatever soap you want i don't give a
flying [ __ ] right like that's their
argument it's it's it's pointless it's
absolutely spineless
there's another dude who's 54 years old
he lives in his mama's basement right
and he talks about all those content
creators and he has been exposed he even
hates his own race he claimed to be an
italian chad i know i know
i know i've i've seen it all john
exposed that loser as well and they all
get exposed eventually i mean they start
to infight they start to expose each
other
like
these people are are folks that exist
they're always going to exist i don't
care they like to talk about us or me
for example the way that i look at it
dollar is i just see it as like they're
they're an unpaid marketing team like
i'm assuming that you watch some of that
stuff right because it sounds like
you're super familiar with it
yeah i i watched some of their content
was so like evil and like yeah yeah so
so i mean like here's the thing and now
you're here watching me so my angle is
let them talk about me let them let me
let them call me names let them point
and sputter at me because what ends up
happening is guys like you will be like
well let me go check out this rich
cooper guy to see what he's talking
about and then the smarter ones that
want to do something with their lives
realize huh he actually makes better
sense in this putts over here i'm going
to stop watching the loser stuff right
so they're actually doing me a favor
they're actually sending
people over to me so that they can wake
up and unplug from the crap that they've
been told
yeah correct that's a good great talking
to you brother good man i appreciate you
hopping on and sharing some experience
we'll see you later
okay
let me uh i've got some supers here that
popped in while i was doing these let me
just catch up here
uh unpopular movie opinion says wasted
much of my life feeling sorry for myself
thanks for the kick in the pants and
want to improve myself stop blaming
everyone else
you're very welcome bro
um
skin in the game said dukkha yup
most don't have skin in the game and
just a little uh super just a little
thank you
yeah and then you know you got infamous
rifle here is done jimmy you know he's
done a he's done a nice expose on a
another loser who was a a face hider who
was exposed um basement dwellers you
know that's what they are
you know guys where's your receipts yeah
where's my receipts
yeah i've only run a business that made
millions of dollars for almost 20 years
i've got supercars in my garage look i
don't care if you don't like me i don't
care if you don't trust me that's fine
go find somebody that you trust that you
that you feel like the message does
something for you you want to go listen
to faceless basement dwellers
have fun with it man have fun with it
honestly
one of the fastest growing companies in
canada voted one of the best places to
work in the world i can go right down
the list of all the awards
but these nerds think that they know
more and what are they selling you watch
my stuff so you can be doom and gloom
too it's loser content it is content
that men must learn to avoid recognize
it and avoid it simple as that
you